i'm laura ingram this is the ingram
angle from washington tonight now the
cdc says the covet vaccine
doesn't actually stop the spread
of the virus
okay so why are we banning unvaccinated
teachers from their own classrooms we
talk to one teacher who's taking her
case to court
and domestic terrorists that's what the
national school board association wants
to label parents who stand up for their
kids plus biden insults the american
people and they're talking back raymond
arroyo has it insane and unseen but
first
big blue cities block america that's the
focus of tonight's angle
well you can't say we didn't tried to
warn them it's becoming more obvious by
the day
that these power hungry governors and
radical mayors are endangering their
state's futures and will eventually see
their states left behind we tried to
warn red and blue states that if they
went the way of europe and kind of slow
rolled their reopenings the free states
would ultimately leave them all behind
and sure enough we see it's all come to
pass
democrat run states and cities that drag
their feet on reopening and continue to
weigh down their businesses and schools
with all these mandates
are bringing down the economy for the
rest of america
one blue bloomberg columnist recently
looked at seven metro regions new york
la san francisco chicago dc boston and
philly
now while all those places accounted for
25 of job losses at the beginning of the
pandemic
they're now responsible for a staggering
44.8 percent of the job losses
and by the way when you break it out
further the picture looks even more grim
the national average unemployment rate
is 5.2 percent but for new york and la
it's over 10
chicago's still atrocious at 8
wow
so why is this happening
because not everyone has the luxury of
working from home people
as one bloomberg column notes many high
skill service workers started to work
remotely as a result
low skill service workers in big cities
bore most of the recent pandemics
economic impact
duh
i mean anyone with a little bit of grey
matter upstairs should have seen this
freight train of an unemployment problem
coming
it's also harmful it's also unnecessary
lawyers and accountants people like that
they did great they were able to take up
knitting and beekeeping
but fauci and the government smug covet
enforcers they didn't consider what they
were doing here
the facts tell us something very
important about what's going on about
the trillions of dollars in new taxing
and spending that biden after everything
we've been through wants to ram through
first of all we don't need any of it
most of the us economy is doing fine
and the blue cities simply need to fully
reopen bring everyone back to work and
just as we've been saying for months
there's plenty of pent-up demand out
there and plenty of job opportunities
for people just getting started in the
workplace
but the blue state mayors your friends
like lori lightfoot eric garcetti bill
de blasio
they refuse they adamantly refuse to do
the right thing and instead
are doing everything possible to prevent
life from returning to normal
here's my message to all the mayors of
america put these mandates in place put
these incentives in place we cannot
maximize the safety of our workplaces
without people being fully vaccinated
that is my
that's my goal
the goal well imagine if these pull
troons operated with the savvy of our
friends in nashville or phoenix now
while the left demands obscene new
levels of spending
this is happening at the same time
energy policies that they're dictating
are having a devastating effect on the
same working people who are getting
hammered on the other side
the cost of oil recently spiked to its
highest price since 2014
and we're already seeing headlines
in june that said you know things are
going to get worse and worse natural gas
going through the roof the bottom line
this winter americans can expect bigger
utility bills
but it's not just utility bills biden's
climate crusade will lead to higher
prices on everything else
natural gas is consumed in large volumes
to make plastic fertilizer steel and
cement
climbing gas prices are adding to the
cost of producing manufactured goods at
a time when investors are on the edge
about the potential for runaway
inflation there it is
now this isn't an accident
it's democratic policy
biden's team and its supporters on the
hill actually want you to travel less to
buy less and frankly to enjoy life less
their war on oil and gas is an immediate
tax on every american that we're going
to pay every day until the gop returns
to power
and now on top of that yeah they want to
spend trillions more
now biden and the left want to radically
change america forever
we need to expand uh medicaid and of
course we need to do something about
expanding uh
medicare one of my non-negotiables is
the child tax credit can you vote for a
bill that does that has the height
amendment in it no
we cannot afford to increase
carbon or just fossil fuel emissions at
this time
now we can't afford you
can you imagine by the way the fraud and
cronyism that this massive level of
spending is going to invite
now as it is the doj can't even keep up
with the ppp fraud
they move the money out so quickly to
people and businesses
now it looks like as much as 15 percent
of it was wrongly awarded one study put
study put the losses at a staggering
billion dollars of ppp fraud
and at the same time that all this is
happening biden is flat out lying to you
he actually claims that we can take
trillions of dollars in money wasted on
foolish government programs and the net
cost is zero
raising the debt limit
is about paying off our old debts
there's nothing to do with any new
spending being considered that's nothing
to do with my plan for infrastructure
or building back better zero
zero
both of which i might add are paid for
now it would be laughable if it weren't
so troubling
but remember desperate men do desperate
things
the democrats are headed for a wipeout
in next year's congressional elections
they know this
they know biden is a failure and they
know harris is worse
so now they're trying to borrow in tax
as much as possible
even though our only economic problems
result from the foolish intransigence of
their own mayors and their own governors
and as they get closer to defeat
they're going to become more unstable
they'll harass people like mansion from
the water
senator this is an investment this is
not giving out money this is not
spending this is investing
they went after center cinema in what
should be a very private moment
so much for dignity and the return to
normal that biden promised us
there's just pathetic people watching
their dream to control americans and
lower their standards of living slipping
away they see it they feel it
of course biden is on board with all
these lunatics the ones that are in the
water the ones are in the bathroom
but come on that was ages ago come on
when
this was joe today the bathroom ambush
well wasn't appropriate but
i don't think they're appropriate
tactics but it happens to everybody
from
the only people it doesn't happen to are
people who have secret service stand
around them um so uh it's it's it's part
of the process
forget mansion and cinema and all this
all 50 senate democrats should be
denouncing this type of behavior their
silence speaks volumes about how far
left the party has gone
the democrats are right to think this
spending debate is their last chance
it's their last chance to show that they
haven't been completely taken over by
the loony left it's their last chance to
show that they still believe in our
basic economic system
and it's their last chance to encourage
that we will return to normal
if they don't take it if they keep
pushing for trillions of dollars in
waste that's going to spur inflation
hurt americans even more the voters will
know whom to blame and that's the angle
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else